if you're watching this and you are  collecting debt to go to college to be a  business person  quint other than the jobs or your stops  I know the cliche ship but I'm talking  business and you're not watching this  form or your [ __ ] so business just does  not have college loans that you can't  even declare bankruptcy to get out of  college is the racket zero reality that  gives you a piece of paper that does not  match to anything that's going on in the  real world send this email to mom sorry  mom  [ __ ] off I don't want you to have wrap  your self-esteem into little Johnny's  life so you can tell your [ __ ]  friends that he goes to darkness  he's gonna [ __ ] lose get him the [ __ ]  out